el campo de refugiados de balata en el
área de nablus fue el escenario de una
nueva redada del ejército israelí en
plena madrugada que dejó la muerte de al
menos tres palestinos armados los
residentes del campo de refugiados más
poblados de si Jordania ocupada
describieron el tamaño de la operación
como el más grande que han visto en los
últimos años hubo un importante
despliegue de vehículos blindados y
también de francotiradores en los techos
de las viviendas los tres militantes
muertos fueron identificados como
miembros de las brigadas de los mártires
de anaxa el brazo armado del partido
oficialista fatal Mientras que otras
seis personas resultaron heridas por su
parte el ejército israelí informó del
arresto de tres sospechosos y de la
destrucción de un supuesto laboratorio
de explosivos según reportes palestinos
esta este estallido ocasionó daños en
las viviendas linderas Mientras que el
Ministerio de salud palestino denunció
que los soldados israelíes bloquearon el
ingreso de ambulancias para atender a
los heridos esta operación fue descrita
como una masacre y un crimen de guerra
por El Vocero del presidente de la
autoridad
palestinaz y no fue la única operación
que se llevó a cabo esta madrugada
porque hubo otra redada en yin y
diversos operativos en menores que se
saldaron con el arresto de al menos una
decena de personas estas redadas son
casi diarias en Jordania ocupadas desde
hace más de un año y se concentran sobre
todo en áreas del Norte donde han
proliferado nuevos grupos armados
haciendo que va de 2023 ya son al menos
119 los palestinos muertos en sijordania
ocupada por fuego israelí mientras que
del lado israelí han muerto 19 personas
en ataques llevados a cabo por
palestinos